wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
wo liegt deine familie immer noch mit
ihm das ist eine schande
als wir in syrien lebten hast du nie
gelogen
seit du dich mit ihm triffst du hast du
das ja wir haben uns nur zufällig
getroffen glaubst du ich bin ein idiot
dieser mann gilt mich an
er bringt dich dazu zu lügen er gab
sogar schon ankunft er ist kein umgang
für dich hey seid wann seht ihr euch
schon das gibt es überhaupt nicht so an
für in ihre viertel sieht es geht nicht
an es geht mich nichts an wenn meine
tochter ihr leben wirklich was sind
deine erwartungen vom leben was sind
seine perspektiven
du hast keine wie willst du für meine
tochter sorgen
ich liebe ihn papa ich liebe dich auch
sinn macht du bist mein einzige tochter
deshalb verbiete ich dir ihn zu selten
zu deinem eigenen vorjahr das können sie
mich
selber
[Musik]